been a rough week for the vp and tonight
it gets a lot worse
white house insiders reportedly unsure
if kamala could beat a republican rival
in 2024
even if it's donald trump looks like her
investigation into root causes at the
border isn't holding up
instead those close to the white house
have lost all faith
telling axios they're concerned about
harris's quote
political tone deafness also here
tonight raymond arroyo a
fox news contributor so raymond i know
you're an expert on kamala you study
every
laugh every trip um
what does this tell you that this
meltdown is occurring so
early less than six months in and now
you have white house insiders already
saying
she's not the heir apparent she's in
trouble well the
look at this point the only thing kamala
harris is running for
is her life from the old executive
office building
look the real reason they're worried
jesse and nobody's really reported this
widely john mclaughlin did a poll
pitting
trump against kamala harris trump beats
her
49 to 45 percent that's why they're
panicking
in the west wing now cedric richmond the
the rep
former representative from louisiana my
old representative
he's saying this is a whisper campaign
to sabotage her
well it's coming from your white house
and why
because the coalition that joe biden was
able to cobble together
they know kamala harris will not be able
to recreate that
remember when she left the presidential
campaign jesse
she was polling in single digits she was
number
six and as far as support from african
americans
she was getting less support than bernie
sanders and elizabeth warren
just for the record yeah she can't
cobble the biden coalition together not
even if she tried
but this is interesting that we're
talking about this now raymond
and i'll explain we should be talking
about this in seven years
joe biden should be looking at a
two-year turn this tells me joe biden
and his insiders
are not necessarily expecting him to run
for re-election perhaps he doesn't make
it
perhaps he can't run for re-election in
2024.
we don't know why but so now we're
considering a possibility of her
stepping in yeah and running in and
running in a primary because you know
the democrats are going to try to
primary kamala harris
in 2024 if joe steps down that is going
to be
bonkers well he's already on record
saying that he will run again now bear
in mind
he'll be 81 years old and if you
suffered i mean listen
to the speeches i listened to today from
joe biden
i'm going to play some of them later
this evening i i can't imagine this at
81.
he's having trouble just putting basic
syntax and stories together
but kamala harris has become the gwen
berry of of politics you know she's
she's divisive she's the heroine hates
the flag
yeah right it's so she's throwing
hammers and divisive but there's very
little to show for it
and her portfolio solving immigration
being the leader on the voting rights
act none of this is panned out jesse
there's no progress that's why they're
worried she's all hat and no cattle
and i think the people in the democratic
party are beginning to look at this
and when they see that john mclaughlin
poll pitting she against trump
it looks awfully bad for the democrats
and i just don't know how you get biden
out there again
in 2024. i just don't see it
all right raymond arroyo who's going to
have some more for us tonight on fox
news
so tune in to raymond thanks raymond i'm
going to spend the weekend reading this
jesse
thank you that's why we love you
enjoy it thank you you'll be on angle
tonight watch that you bet see you later
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else